Mr President great to have you back
thank you so much all right here's this
big beautiful book Letters what an
incredible yeah well and here's what is
even more incredible is well first of
all you save things I don't save
anything I throw everything out I can't
find anything uh I have somewhere at my
brother-in-law's house you know tapes
from when I started radio in 87 I was on
the Donahue show Sally Jesse and Geraldo
I did all those shows too and back in
the day even even The View with Rosie
O'Donnell which you would be proud of me
um but here's what's amazing you've kept
all of these letters you know one letter
goes back to 1987 and Richard Nixon
telling you if you run you will win the
relationships that you had John Kennedy
Jr letters from Reagan you had a
relationship with Ted Kennedy I'm not a
fan of his but you but interesting Billy
Graham Kirk Douglas Michael Jackson Kim
Jong-un you put all of these incredible
you you save those things so I was lucky
I had two really great executive
assistants one was Norma one was Rona
and uh Norma was a fantastic woman she
passed away Rona took her place
incredibly did a great job I remember
Rona and Rona also saved the letters and
they had a system that was amazing I
mean I have a letter from Andrew Lloyd
Webber inviting me saying essentially
that I'm opening a new musical in New
York it's called Phantom of the Opera I
think it might be good would you like to
come he lived in Trump Tower with Sarah
Brightman actually they were married and
uh I said yeah I'd like to go and I went
I heard the music I said that's
phenomenal but I have so many letters
like that and I have letters from Rosie
O'Donnell before politics she thought I
was great she asked me to be in her
movie Oprah Winfrey I have letters
Whoopi Goldberg against me to be in her
movie they all asked me to be in there
Oprah asked me to run I mean I think she
was being she wanted you guys to run as
a team she said would be a great team
uh I get along with the great she was at
Mar-A-Lago many times but this is an
interesting phenomenon you mentioned
Rosie you mentioned Oprah we talk about
Ted Kennedy
that you get in the world of politics
and then all of a sudden people that
were your friends or they said they said
they were your friends they sent you the
most lovely letters
they're not your friends anymore so an
interesting thing happened uh I was
going to a big Charity Dinner Robin Hood
Foundation it was at the convention
center in New York big big space big
success and I went in and as I'm going
there thousands of fans outside
and I was booed by about 30 40 percent
of the people booed a little bit I had
just announced I was running
and my wife turned out to be a very
great first lady people love her
Melania said to me I've never heard you
booed before ever I've been with you for
a long time you've never been booed
before
I said welcome to politics but it's true
I wasn't booed I was really liked by
everybody I gave up a lot to do this I
have to do the right thing I mean I know
what's popular what's not but I also
know what has to be done and sometimes
that's not popular
and you do get booed but uh I gave up a
lot to do this I was really like my
favorite when you see some of those
letters when you see the Rosie
O'Donnell's and and other people that
truly if you believe them they hate me
now oh yeah I could give you names of
people that I think actually love me now
but they don't say it but uh and they
also love paying a lot less tax you know
that that's sort of good I guarantee you
they went in there they voted for Trump
and even if they don't say it you
received the letter from Barack Obama
the day you became president and you
left a letter for Joe Biden the day he
became president
yeah you've never talked about them
I think it's a very personal thing I
think it's for them to talk about
actually Joe Biden said I received the
letter was a very nice letter he did and
uh I just think that it would be for
them to release it if they wanted to put
the letter from Obama to you yeah it's
being released people yeah letters to
Trump bookstores everywhere amazon.com
hannity.com thank you very much we
appreciate it thank you so much thank
you very much appreciate it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else